well he's just a real comedian I mean
that's what that guy is you can't get
him to do anything else no dude his
wedding was hilarious I bet dude he's I
see it like you can tell he's a guy
who's trained himself on you know
deflecting never like being emotional
ever being honest or not honest open and
then dude he was so uncomfortable in
what's supposed to be the best moment of
your life he's just like like there's no
there's no way to do a pun like he was
squirming it was like I was I sitting
there you had to be serious to just be
like tell his wife how he loved her and
he's just like can I call her
gay
comedy oh my God the text message
chain that I have with him and Shane we
have a we have a protect our Park's text
message Shan and every now and then
he'll chime in with a Norman yeah
these singers his work's different
than anybody's yeah he's it's the most
like he's just looking for a pun first
and foremost